est ce le petit grégory villemin a été
inhumé cet après midi à lépanges sur
vologne
une cérémonie d'autant plus poignante
étendue que les enquêteurs ne cachaient
pas leur présence pour tenter de faire
progresser l'enquêté
certains membres de la famille s'en sont
pris à la presse sur place
isabelle bechler la petite église du
village accueille rarement autant de
monde aujourd'hui plus de 600 personnes
se sont pressées là pour accompagner le
corps de l'enfant assassiné pour
soutenir jean marie et christine
villemin ses parents ou pour voir tout
simplement
l'ambiance est lourde on sait pillon de
phase iib croire la surveillance des
gendarmes est discrète mais on sait déjà
qu'ils ont conseillé à quatre personnes
de la famille au moins de ne pas venir
pour éviter les incidents
il s'agit du clan rival celui de jackie
le demi frère de jean-marie douze mains
on a beaucoup pleuré dans l'église
tout au long de la messe mais soudain
quand le petit cercueil est transporté
jusqu'au caveau
c'est comme si tous l'absurde et
l'horreur de cette mort frappe et enfin
les esprits de plein fouet trois femmes
sont tour à tour pris d'un malaise
christine la mère de grégory et les deux
grand mère de l'enfant
soudain il devient insoutenable de
penser que peut-être l'assassin est
aussi au cimetière et tout le monde
craque
c'est un peu ce que les gendarmes
chargés de l'enquêté attendaient le choc
psychologique de l'enterrement va peut
être délié les langues qui aurait
répugné jusque là à parler du secret de
la grande famille
en effet aussi abominable que cela
paraisse les recherches dans le milieu
professionnel sont restées vaines
c'est donc vers la famille que tous les
soupçons sont désormais tournés